in the continuing saga of the Trump
administration simply refusing to do
what Trump says they're going to do
we've now heard from national security
advisor John Bolton Trump's latest
national security adviser who says yeah
we're actually not withdrawing troops
from Syria at least not right now
even if Donald Trump thinks or says that
we are and this is exactly what a white
house in chaos looks like remember that
Trump said a couple of weeks ago that we
won we defeated Isis we're getting out
of Syria we're pulling all troops out of
Syria john bolton said well we might at
some point pull our troops out of syria
but there's actually a long list of
things that need to happen and and
there's a number of conditions that need
to be met in order for us to actually do
that
so John Bolton's perspective on Syria
which is completely different from what
we were led to believe by Donald Trump
just weeks ago is we still have things
to accomplish in Syria actually Isis
hasn't been defeated actually we're not
going to leave until not only is Isis
defeated but until the Kurds are
actually protected in a way that we can
trust that air dhawan and Turkey aren't
- going to go in and absolutely decimate
them and we also need to make a plan
with our foreign allies about what is
going to happen once we actually do
leave consider that you have a guy who
is making decisions so haphazard and not
thought through and and outrageous that
john bolton one of the most eager
architects of the Iraq war part of the
project for a new American Century this
wacky neoconservative think-tank John
Bolton is serving as a sort of
moderating voice of reason with Donald
Trump that's how whacked things have
gotten at this point I would now ask who
is actually in control of Trump's
administration beyond when Trump just
makes an initial statement because
remember that when Trump went on Twitter
and announced the anti-transgender
military policy Jim Madison the Pentagon
multiple times said we're not actually
doing it right now
madis was travelling when Trump tweeted
about it there's not actually a plan or
any plan that we are even developing
right now to find and discharge
transgender military members period this
is sort of the same thing Pat this is
once again Trump announcing a policy it
has the immediate impact of sending the
stock markets into chaos fueling
instability and then we hear from John
Bolton
yeah actually Isis is still there and
we're not leaving and a whole bunch of
stuff needs to happen before it's
something we can really do and Trump
announcing that we were going to pull
out of Syria that was a big reason why
defense secretary Jim mattis left and
chief of staff John Kelly left before
him it's honestly too bad that those
were the two people to leave and not
John Bolton because Madison Kelly well I
don't agree with them on everything they
were certainly moderating voices and at
least I think we're looking out for the
best interest of the country whereas
they can't say the same thing about John
Bolton it's honestly unfortunate that
Bolton was able to stick it out stick
through this and apparently convinced
Trump to stay in Syria yeah and this is
actually the worst of all worlds if you
are a principled person who is opposed
Syrian intervention in the first place
like many people in our audience totally
reasonable logical position but at the
same time you're concerned that Trump is
being manipulated by foreign powers be
it Russia or turkey or Saudi Arabia or
whatever into making this decision to
leave Syria we now have a situation
where Trump wants to leave Syria
possibly for all of the wrong reasons
but we're actually still going to stay
so we may simultaneously have a guy
making a decision to pull troops for all
the wrong reasons
but we might still want the troops
pulled but they're not even actually
going to be pulled because John Bolton
is saying yeah what we're not actually
doing that so if you're for transparency
about why we make geopolitical decisions
and you're against Syrian intervention
you're losing twice here we're staying
despite Trump possibly being blackmailed
or some kind of quid pro quo or being
pushed to leave by a foreign power and
wanting to leave Bolton wants to stay in
partially because he's a war hawk neocon
and he just wants the u.s. in the region
in as many places as possible for as
long as possible it's
horrible Trump wants us out we don't
even really know why but there are all
sorts of possibilities many of which are
extraordinarily nefarious it's the kind
of blind leading the blind or the
corrupt working with the amoral I don't
know what analogy or metaphor you want
to use and then now of course we have
Trump screwing up the non pull out pull
out Trump says we're out
Boulton says were actually not and then
Trump comes in yesterday and says well
we might look to Iran and Russia as
allies against Isis in Syria when we
pull out which is of course I'll find
well and good except that again saying
we can leave because Russia will take
over Russia and Putin's interests are in
supporting the brutal Assad regime under
the guise of saying that they are
fighting Isis so everything going wrong
here in an absolutely embarrassing way
send me your thoughts about the send me
your thoughts about this latest
confirmation that as crazy as Trump's
idea is it's not even happening and
who's in charge there anyway I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show today's
sponsor is Skillshare and I'm excited to
tell you that everybody in our audience
is getting two entire months of free
access to Skillshare when you click the
link underneath this video skill shares
the site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop managing a small
business almost an endless list and
whether you're trying to get ahead in
your career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make you better at your
job you might just be exploring a new
hobby and you're trying to find new ways
to be creative in your personal time
skill shares the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in whatever you're
trying to learn I really enjoyed the
class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the david packard show
for the last few years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of that
assess you every single class offered by
Skillshare after those two months if you
want to keep your subscription
Skillshare super affordable at less than
ten bucks a month get better at whatever
it is that you're passionate about or
discover something brand-new that you
didn't even know that you would love and
join skill shares other 7 million users
by clicking the link underneath this
video
[Music]